welcome back guys my name is matt you're
watching demo rpg episode 15 we're
writing a c plus plus uh rpg library
from scratch sort of top down old no it
doesn't necessarily need to top down
just old school systems like final
fantasy style and d d and stuff and uh
yeah this episode we're gonna work on
monsters but first i've done a ton of
just uh
off episode stuff so there's gonna be an
update i'll leave a link to it down
below that's basically going to be like
14.5 or something or episode 14.5
because i did a ton of work refactoring
but i didn't want to make that an
episode on its own because we only have
six episodes left i know can you believe
it but
if i get like 10 new patrons before the
end of the series i'll do a few more
bonus episodes so consider signing up on
patreon help support these as they don't
particularly do
super well on youtube in general and it
makes it hard for me to
basically determine that's worth my time
to do these so it does rely on the
community support some but i am
committed to doing at least 20 no matter
what
that being said let's go over the
changes that happened
in between last episode and this episode
i'm not gonna talk about every single
one because they're just too huge but
basically we took every single dot h
file from over here
and turned it into or gave it an
associated.cpp so let's just look at one
as an example let's check out buff here
now there's only definitions here
basically this since this is now library
we don't want the definitions in the dot
h so we look at the associated buff file
and you'll notice all the headers that
could be used by the end user are in
this include demo rpg and everything
else is flat that's because uh yeah we
don't want them including the
definitions the definitions are part of
the dot live that's just how the library
works they only need to know about the
function names
all right so if we look at buff we'll
see all the definitions are in there and
that's true down the line for basically
any of these if you look at them
it's now no definitions here oh there's
one here actually we missed so there's a
little thing that we could correct so
feel free to correct that if you want
i'm not going to do it right now because
we're moving on and it seems to compile
fine
uh yeah the item if we go to item let's
see we got well that's i guess not a
great case but everything else is fine
we also pulled out
armor potion uh weapon
all the items we did separate out of uh
the item
class itself the item class itself is
just the delegates basically and the
final item that you actually use
so that changes things same with the
classes all the player character classes
well the main
uh include of just player character has
the delegate and the one you instantiate
but all these subclasses of rogue and
everything are all on their own and
that's just so we can easily modify them
as we go because these are
going to include all the level up code
and class trees but otherwise still
mostly the same
and now let's look at one last thing
that i want to talk about here as far as
changes and that is i have added a lot
of uh whatever these are called
qualifiers i guess i think is what
they're called to uh functions so a lot
of them have no discard which basically
means hey if you're using one of these
getters
you actually have to be doing something
with the value otherwise it's going to
throw you a warning potentially an error
on your compiler and that's just so no
one's calling get level and then just
not doing anything with the actual level
returns because why you calling get
level so just a way to help us code
later to get more warnings and stuff if
we're doing something wrong also added a
lot of const and no except
no except basically tells the compiler
learner that this cannot throw an
exception which helps it optimize things
so that's good and const is basically to
help us down the line to make sure well
the constant on this left side says you
cannot modify this type it's returning
so don't modify it
and if you do it's going to throw an
error and this one on the right side
means it can't change anything in the
class well if it's a getter it shouldn't
be changing anything in the class so
that makes sense so we added a whole
bunch of those down the line just for
everything it's pretty straightforward
all these getters are going to be no
discard const and const no except uh
like 90 percent of the time and that's
just going to help
efficiency in coding and
you'll notice i capitalize all the
public functions i'm trying to stay
consistent with that i may have missed a
few you're welcome to make pull requests
and fix any of those i missed and get
some github points if you want and also
in general for private members i started
them with underscore and uh just
left all lower case with underscores in
between words uh just to make it clear
that they're private
if we're accessing them in the item
manager or something so i tried to go
through every class and do that
in general
as you'll see it looks the same here
and uh yeah i moved hp mp abilities and
buffs into the player character delegate
slash stat block
because well it seemed to be the place
for it and as we get to making some
monsters we're going to decide if we use
this player character delegate for
monsters or not i'm thinking right now
that i'm not going to because we just
want to keep monsters really simple we
got to decide if we want them to level
up and stuff but anyway that's the main
changes that we're starting from
so i'm going to leave the the starting
link if you want to start from here for
today for what we're doing and that way
you can actually code along because
there's just a bunch of stuff that
wasn't in episodes
so just a reminder to uh hit like
subscribe to the channel and if you want
to see me live coding or gaming head
over to my twitch check me out over
there if you have twitch prime you can
give me a free sub and it helps me out
so there are free ways to
support the channel and uh yeah the
thing with patreon stands too if i get
10 new members before the end of this i
will extend it a few episodes uh
basically i'll go to episode 22.
all right and with that out of the way
let's get on to monsters oh sorry one
last thing i want to mention yes we are
going to move on to monsters but what
made this all very possible was that we
have a bunch of tests so yeah i wrote a
bunch more tests too so i totally forgot
to mention that but
yeah having all these tests and if we go
look at any of them in particular you
can see exactly what they do
basically we're checking the first two
levels of every class to make sure it
gets everything it's supposed to get and
some armor and items and stuff and a
quick player
and making sure the backpack works
there's a change to the backpack too
where if you try to equip a potion it
puts it into your inventory you can
equip armor and stuff directly but if
you try it you know it's still going to
swap to your inventory so inventory
still needs a little bit of work but
we'll be updating that
basically all these functions are going
to have to keep the player inventory in
mind or whatever inventory you're
pulling from so that it can update
the chest or inventory or whatever
you're digging out of so yeah
these changes were a lot easier thanks
to having
both an ide that helps along with it
because hey say you want to change this
function you just ctrl r do the
check everything that should change do
okay and give it a new name
level care up for example if you just
want to change the name of something you
can do that apply it across everything
run your test
to make sure it took
and bam we can see it worked correctly
so
yeah refactoring is a lot easier with a
good ide is what i'm saying uh it
becomes a nightmare for using a plain
text editor and you want to change
things throughout the thing but also i
should mention that sometimes this
doesn't do it perfectly sometimes you go
to change something and it totally
messes up and doesn't get certain things
so just keep all that in mind
it changed here changed it everywhere
basically yeah so tests are a big deal
and once we get these monsters in here
we're going to have them fight some
players via some tests all right now for
real
so yeah download this starting code and
then we'll get into it
all right on to monsters how are we
gonna do monsters now let's keep it
really simple because of course we could
get super complicated give all kinds of
varying abilities and rotations and
stuff but for now we're just gonna keep
it super simple and basically just make
a monster class
and all they're really going to do is
have hp in an attack
so let's just keep it really that simple
so we're going to have public
private
and if you missed what i did there i
basically just uh right clicked on this
and went to add new class
or new item chose
class and then gave it a name and that
should make the starter.h cpp
so let's find where it put it it usually
puts these on the root level we actually
want the dot h to be in the include over
here let's go ahead and move that
make sure we hit save on those in the
cpp here and there we go
and we're good there so what are we
going to have publicly and privately
here let's see
well we want a constructor
oh it didn't capitalize it
so we need to do that and we need to do
right over here too
all right so a monster is definitely
going to have
hp let's go ahead and include types
we're going to use those
let's also go ahead and include
point well we're going to use that for
hp and i think that's really all we need
for now since we're just going to keep
it really really simple
so let's make a unique pointer
of the point well and actually this can
be public because the way
the way this class is made
unique
pointer
point well
hp
so let's go ahead and include memory
yeah because uh hp is the way it is
where
it's a class of its own and it can't be
modified except through its functions uh
yeah the current fullness and maxwell
are
maxwell sounds funny but it's probably
just be max the current and max
should be you know what let's just go
ahead and hot edit these just as a
little practice
uh it is
let's just change this to current
using our refactor button well let's
change this one to max
and that should update across all the
code everywhere and we're good
so yeah even if we have public access to
hp we still can't directly modify its
max and current we have to use these
functions for getting and setting
so it's uh yeah it's just the way we
have designed so that's that's kind of
interesting all right so we got our hp
what else does a monster need well
probably needs an attack
and we can just make that however we
want
do we want it to be const or do we want
it to be able to be modified do we want
them to be able to get buffs well these
are things we can decide later for now
let's just have
a un32
[Music]
well we can go damage type we have
damage type
yeah men damage you know we could do a
min and a max but then we'd have to
bring in randomization we're actually
going to bring in some randomization
for this episode um yeah
but for right now
yeah let's do it min and max is fine so
damage type
men damage and i guess we could just do
it like this max damage and we could
make those private
sense we don't want people modifying
them and let's go no discard
damage type
get min damage const no except
let's do the same thing for max
and we could have setters too but let's
just say that they have to specify in
here
uh
well type hp and then damage
type
men and damage type max
so now
they just have to use this constructor
to make a monster we could even delete
all the other ones like we can go
monster
move delete and we could do the other
ones too we go monster
uh
cons monster reference sequels delete i
think that's right
and this other one with uh double
reference
also delete copy and move constructors
get rid of those
are there others we need to get rid of i
can't remember maybe but now we just
need to make these functions and we want
these functions to be in the cp class so
i'm just going to
use some help here and alt
enter while having hovering over it and
we get a create definition option
sometimes it works sometimes it doesn't
it basically starts putting some code
here in this monster.cpp uh brings it up
in a little shortcut here it's just a
visual studio thing but basically we
know what we want to do we just want to
go hb equals
new or uh standard make unique rather
because
hp is a unique pointer why does this
need to be a unique pointer it doesn't
honestly it doesn't
you know in this case
did we have a reason for it before uh we
did but i don't remember what it was
all right so let's just not make it one
in this case that's
that's fine it's still going to have the
same rules from its class it's just
going to make it a little easier
to do this sort of thing actually we can
even
just
construct them like so
and go
min damage
min
max damage
max
and bring these brackets up here get our
formatting key see if it's happy
seems happy i don't know why this one
isn't oh it's because hp
does oh yeah it wants uh it wants the
min and max
so we want to start the monster full hit
points that's just the way our class is
you gotta pass it twice because if we go
look at it just address this real quick
the constructor you either give it a
blank constructor or you either give it
nothing or you give it a current and a
max so we want the current and max to be
the same so that's why we got to pass it
this hp twice
and there we go that should set up our
monster for some base cases
and of course we want to design this get
men we'll do the same thing over it hit
alt enter
and make it return men damage
and we might do these a different way
and now i'll think about here but
basically it's of course going to be max
damage
as you can see we don't need to put no
discard in here twice did i do that with
other stuff where it wasn't needed i
might have yeah i guess you don't need
the no discard in the cpp file only in
the header i wasn't real sure on that
but it appears that when you use the
auto create function it doesn't bring it
over it does bring over a constant and
no except speaking of these should also
be const nonst
because we don't want to be changing
these values
as we bring them in
or as we get them
now another thing we probably want here
and this is where some randomization
comes in is we probably want
an attack method and we probably want
this for the both the character
and the monster because we're gonna have
them fight but yeah as you might expect
when we do an attack since we don't just
have a flat damage amount we want to
randomize between min and max this is
optional some games just do a flat
amount you know you add your modifiers
of strength and whatever but
we're gonna do a little bit of random
damage because we have a min and a max
and it's kind of the point of it is to
run in between those numbers so i'm
going to show you how to do that real
quick mainly we're going to use chrono
and random now i've already built this a
million times
so i'm not going to do it again
basically if you go on over to github
uh i'm just gonna find myself
and i'm just gonna dig and look for
random
where did i put this
somewhere in here
i have random there it is rand now all
this is is just some
some really basic if you look at the dot
h i'll leave a link to this down below
as a dll version
but basically it just has some little
random functions and you see how they're
building this dot cpp
um
this is like 0 2 1 random float 0 to 1
random
there's all different types like this
one is a
i think it's a
double yeah this one's a float this
one's a double
this one is
zero or one random this is n to k random
uh integers
floats doubles we only need this integer
one really so i'm just going to grab
this code right here copy it
that's the end to kr that's uh basically
n two k whatever two numbers you give it
and r stands for random and we're just
going to make a little
little file here actually we'll make a
cpp file
called
random
and that should go on the root level
oops i kind of want it to be lowercase
actually
there we go and
we're just going to put this function in
here
and it's going to be a little confused
about a few things like doesn't know
what stuff is so let's just fix that
so we're gonna include
what are we gonna need corono because we
are getting a time seed based on the
current time of your computer that way
it's different random every time because
it's gonna be a different seed every
time you use it
that way our program is not predictably
random and you can't say oh if you do
this thing first thing in the game then
it's always this value it's not going to
happen since it's going to seed on time
and time's always different
and we need some other stuff here i
believe this is going to
uh
i gotta look actually what is it
random and chrono okay
it's random
so that's all you need here
basically you're gonna pass this these
two values and
it should work now let's just see what
happens if we pass this un32t
let's see if we can
fix it up a little bit and just see what
happens here
and we're gonna give it a okay the seeds
already uh 32 the distribution type
it should work
uh the standard mt is merson twister so
we're using merson twister so since
these are also static they only happen
once any time you call the function
and that's intended
we also want this to be no discard
because why are you calling random if
you're not using the value it returns
we also want this to be
cons 12 constant matters not a class
well we can probably make a class
or actually let's just make it a name
space you could make a class but we're
going to make it namespace
random
because we're also going to make this
static and over here let's see what we
want we probably just want no except so
can't throw exceptions so random is not
very well testable in general because
the problem with random
is uh if you run something like valve
grind to do memory checks to see if
anything's leaking if you have right if
you have this kind of function you're
somewhere in your code
viral garand is not going to be able to
tell because this is not an easily
testable library uh just throwing that
out there so you're aware but that's
something some people want to hit my key
all right so there we go now to call
this
we're going to have to grab it with x
turn we probably do want to grab to just
put a header of it after all let's just
do it new item
random.h
and it's going to be essentially the
same code except now we're just gonna
have this
random.h
uh we're just gonna have
this code here that way we can
use it from whoever includes the library
back in the namespace standard
and there we go now it knows about it so
we just got to remember this function
name and then it's in
right actually i'm going to take this
car off the r off of there because we're
already in namespace random that's going
to specify it enough i think let's go
back down here
take this r off and we know that we
don't need this no discard
and uh back in dot h so let's just make
sure this is actually static
like so
all right
very good so now let's go back into
monster or monster.h and let's just
let's just go uh
let's return a uint
or let's return a damage type one is
damage type damage type is how you went
32 okay that's fine so we should
probably use that everywhere
uh
attack
if we call get attack
or just attack it's going to return
uh let's make this no cons no accept
it's not changing anything and it
returns damage type which we want to be
no discard
and we also want to be cons
we might not even use these get men get
max because we can just call this attack
or maybe you know we gotta decide melee
attack maybe we do melee range now let's
keep it let's keep it really simple
we're not going to worry about that so
let's build this attack function
yeah so let's go into the actual cp file
here and basically what we want to do is
we want to include our random
random.h this should be lowercase
and we want to make sure that this uses
into that into k so let's go scope it
into random into k pass it the min
damage
and max damage
and now
uh let's go back into random real quick
we probably want these uns to be damage
type if we think about it because well i
guess you know we might need separate
random functions for other kinds of
stuff but this one will work for the
damage
so maybe it'd be better if we did some
sort of template for this so we could
pass it different values easier we're
not going to worry about it right now
it's damage only it's going to work fine
let's just build it it's going to return
a random value using bin and max so
whatever the min and max should are
it should be at least the min no higher
than the max now we could sort of test
that
but we also want to build this attack
the same function
into the player so let's go to player
character and let's see where do we hold
our min and max damage nowhere that's
basically based on their equipped
weapons and armor
so i guess it makes sense
to put it into put the delicate here or
into the uh
substantiation of player character
which takes a pc class but yeah let's
just put it there right there
uh same function uh we want melee and
range cell here because we can equip
melee or ranged melee attack and let's
go arranged attack
and let's just build these real quick
and we'll test them here in a second
they're essentially going to be the same
let's just make this profile let's go
all the way up to the top
and we're now going to include random
because we're going to need to random
some damage here
all right well
we need to consider a few things what's
a melee attack do if you're if you don't
have anything equipped so we probably
want to do
get equipped at right and then
decide how it's going to work from there
so let's just do that
let's just uh anytime you call melee
attack let's instantiate a new damage
temp uh
damage
done all right let's just start this at
zero
should be damage type not just damage
all right because we're going to return
whatever this value does but we're going
to work with a little bit so we're going
to turn
temp damage
i could spell there we go
so if nothing ends up happening it's
going to return zero but in general we
want to go
so if you have a melee weapon equipped
weapon at
uh let's
just do a null check here it gets
equipped
weapon at i'm going to cast it to an
unsigned long long unsigned long long
and it's got to be
this equipped at that slot
so it's going to be
weapon slot melee
so if this returns true then they are if
this yeah if this is true that means i
do have an equipped weapon if it's false
they don't have an equipped weapon so
that's something we have to to think
about now we probably only want to do
this get equipped once so let's actually
bring it outside of this and just go
uh
melee weapon let's go i guess we could
just do
you know
let's do a cast here const
um pointer oh capitalized weapon weapon
pointer
temp weapon
or maybe we just call this
whips weapon
so we are creating a pointer and we're
just going to see if this exists or not
so this does return a const weapon
so that's why this has got to be const
as well and we'll just do get equipped
at same code as before
and then we can just check if this is
null or not
if equipped weapon
then temp damage
done is going to equal
uh random okay
and we need to get the min damage of
that weapon equipped weapon
men damage
with weapon max damage
very good so we're going to get a random
value between the min and max of that
melee else
like uh what are the what's the
unarmed damage
we'll just say
temp damage done
equals one unarmed attack
all right and now we probably want to
modify this with some some strength or
something so we can go ahead and do that
so let's just add like maybe well we're
going to decide on a formula maybe half
our strength or a quarter of our
strength is bonus damage we'll just do
that
add
one quarter of strength and bonus melee
damage
because why not so we'll just take
whatever that value ended up being 10
damage
done plus equals
get
uh let's see we have it somewhere up
here we're just going to take the pc
class stat yeah let's do it directly now
actually you know we want the total so
if we look at all these class values
here
we want to get
total strength because things could be
modifying it so we want to get you know
all the bonus strength from armor and
weapons and magical items and stuff so
we're just going to use that function
to get total
strength
and just divide it by 4 and we'll cast
whatever that ends up being
and 2 damage type
and that should handle the rounding for
us and there we go
so
yeah that should make sense to you get
total strength divided by four add that
to the damage and boom we got us a nice
little melee attack that that does some
random or if you got uh min and max
damage and if you're unarmed it's just
one plus your strength
and we're looking pretty good there or
maybe we could even say zero plus your
strength because maybe maybe your attack
does no damage at all if you're really
weak yeah i like that better
so we're setting it equal
to zero again when it's already zero
that's kind of redundant let's just go
like this
or actually we don't even need this else
case
and we can just say
um now we'll just put some code here or
some comments if weapon exists get the
damage
else the damage the
base
damage
stays
zero okay yeah that works well enough
and we want to do essentially the same
thing for a melee attack so let's just
go at our ranged attack rather
but we'll use agility or something i
don't know we got to decide but it's
essentially going to be this same code
but you know to to for to have a ranged
attack you sort of need to
actually have a ranged weapon you can't
you can't just have an attack without
one so maybe we don't want to add any
bonus damage to this
so it could just be zero
yeah i guess if you
do a ranged attack yeah we'll just make
it zero that mean that's kind of silly
because it's still gonna like
technically let you call the function
it's just gonna return zero damage
so i don't know we might have to work
with that in our battle system a little
bit but that should work for now
no bonus damage on there or we could
just say
now let's do bonus damage let's do get
total agility this time
but we're going to make this a little
bit differently because
uh you actually have to have
a ranged weapon
if equipped weapon then increase the
damage by yeah whatever your agility is
so you'll get some bonus damage based on
your agility on this one maybe it should
be strength because you could pull back
your bow harder or whatever but yeah
we're not gonna worry about it we're
just we're just going to get it done and
we'll just call this
border badge as bonus range damage
[Music]
so there we go yep it's going to stay
zero if you don't have a quick weapon
and now since we're doing this check
twice we can actually just put this code
right here it makes a little more sense
let's comment right here
there we go i actually have to
have that weapon equipped to get any
damage and the bonus if you have nothing
it's just going to return zero and you
did zero damage with your ranged attack
which
is fine
because it essentially will do nothing
as expected you just can't do it i guess
you could still do it you know you just
like go huh i threw something at you
pretend zero damage i don't know
whatever
so
we don't want to overthink it i guess
that's the point let's just close that
out and with the monster we're not even
going to worry about ranged attacks
right now let's just keep it more simple
we're probably going to inherit from
this and do special stuff later but
we're we'll worry about that when the
time comes so now we can make attacks we
can take damage and we can do all sorts
of stuff like that
between the monster and players so we
can actually make them battle now but
let's make a few new tests real quick
for these new functions we added
well let's go ahead and make a test that
is basically a little pseudo battle but
also we just want to do some damage
tests as well so let's go back to our
test class here and let's go
i guess we can do it put it anywhere but
let's just go all the way to the bottom
and just go test method
and we'll just call it
just monster
for now
and we want to just test set up a new
monster and confirm that it works right
basically
so monster one we can call whatever
and we need to construct it with some hp
and stuff so maybe it has a 10 hp min
damage of 2 max damage of 4 and that's
all we need to know about it but of
course we need to include monster
otherwise it's not going to know what it
is naturally we're just doing it on that
pch
it's fine all right so now let's just
let's just make some assertions so let's
assert that it has 10 hit points
is equal
or
r equal rather
r equal 10 and monster1.hp
dot get max will get current
go ahead and cast that to an end so it
can know what to do with it
and we should find out that that's okay
why is visual studio underlining it and
complaining beats me it just does that
okay so it looks like
we have a few complaints here
this whole no except it doesn't like no
except
because we didn't define it is that
right
monster okay so let's just dig into this
it's saying static function
no except declared but not defined see
okay so we have some differences here
we have no except on
this version but do we have it on the
one
where we actually yeah it's here
i'm talking about it's possible that we
can't use no except here
because sometimes
if you're well if you're writing a no
accept function
and you're calling functions that can
throw exceptions it's not valid because
it's not no except if you're calling
other things that can throw exceptions
so let's just take it off of there and
see if that fixes the issue maybe it's
something else
it still says declare but not defined
what
so we must have spelled something wrong
is all i can
assume here
looks the same to me
well let's just try commenting this out
and then
just let it create itself
okay and we'll put all this code in here
uncommented
and see if it's happy now
well i guess
it just doesn't like the fact this is
static let's take the static off still
not too happy about it
why are you no happy
oh un 32 is undefined okay so we just
need to include c standard and
so that's probably the actual problem
yeah we do want this to be static
okay
and we'll just run into another issue it
looks like this one might be a little
different just also once that here
i don't know apparently the static is
it's not okay there i guess it's fine we
still have the main variables in here
static so
that's fine
and now it's just complaining about our
monster code well let's have a dig into
that and see what the problem is looks
fine there
i don't think this attack can be no
except because it uses random basically
that's probably going to cause some
issues let's go check that out take off
this no except
hit build again see if it's happy
says we're missing a semicolon before
that is
not true at all we have all the
semicolons we need so what is really
going on
just doesn't like instantiating oh it's
because we can't call this monster it's
it's a already taken name
so let's just call this
enemy monster to sure whatever now we
should be able to do some more stuff
does not have overloaded operator oh
yeah yeah this is not a unique pointer
it's just an actual variable
there we go and now we should be able to
run our test and let's just see that the
monster has this basic stuff sorted out
run
yep seems to get the proper hp
we also want to just assert that the
damage is two and four
get min damage oh not from hp get min
damage
and basically just you know confirm that
our basics are right it's typically what
you want to do in a test
let's go ahead and run that test again
we don't need to run them all we already
know the others pass so we'll just run
this one make sure it passes
and now we can do some stuff with the
attack so how do we want to do this we
know that the attack should be between
man and max so what if we go assert
that have a less than no
let's just look through all these and
see if we got now we don't really have a
less than so random is kind of hard to
test because well
we could just use
something like is true
over and over so for example let's make
a for loop um
whatever we use the variable i
started at zero and just uh
what do we want to go to i don't know
how many times do we want to test the
randomization let's just say well i is
less than 100 that's a lot of times
we'll probably make it less
and then you know iterate through i and
uh
well let's just do something like this
we'll just do git damage a bunch of
times so let's make a variable i'll
instantiate it up here so we don't keep
recreating it and we'll just say
ant
damage
rando
not sure start at zero and just go
damage rando equals
monster one dot get the attack or attack
rather
and it should do between two and four
damage
over and over why isn't it like this
unlike i for some reason
i don't know it'll be fine oh we're
using
typo here
okay so we want to determine that this
that something here is true so
we need a case here uh let's just say
it's less than five so let's go damage
rando
less than five
we want to assert that that's true every
time and we also want to assert that
it's greater than two
so we'll just go through this 100 times
get the random damage
or greater than one rather
and just basically this is just going to
assert that it's between two and four
every single time so let's go ahead and
run this
so you know 100 iterations of getting
that attack should be pretty solid
little check
and we can even take it a step further
and make it modular and say it should be
less than the max damage or i guess we
could use less than equal
less than or equal to the max damage and
greater than equal to the min damage
kind of a heavy function
but that should make it so that it
doesn't matter what we change these two
like if we do routine between 10 and
i don't know 40 for example we should be
able to
adjust accordingly
and since we're using
get men get max it should work and maybe
we want to go through this a thousand
times but you're starting to see the
point here we basically want to test
that all the random is working correctly
this should have no chance of failing it
does fail what happened here
expected 40
oh i got these backwards
i'm saying get men multiple times hit
max
and you got that
it should be get max okay now it should
fail
so very good we caught an error based on
our typo and it failed again why'd it
fail this time
we got these backwards
this one should be max
this one should be min all right
and let's let's just flip that order
makes more sense to me
very good our tests are doing what
they're supposed to do they're calling
out our mistakes and now it succeeds i
went through this a thousand times
randomized damage and it was fine every
time
pretty cool
pretty cool
so we can pretty well assume yeah we
don't need this many tests that's
excessive let's stick with lower numbers
here
but you get the point this should uh
this definitely fails sometimes
and assert doesn't have a less than or
greater than so that's why we have to do
it in this loopy way there's no less
than
i think you know some test formats do or
maybe has is it is less no it just
doesn't have just doesn't have that
insert
that's fine we can just do it in this
sort of way with uh the check right in
there and make sure it's true or false
as expected and now let's try to battle
let's call this
simple
battle
but before we make this method we did
write a new thing in the characters so
we want to test in any of these
characters that the you know the attack
actually works i guess maybe that'll
that'll be in the simple battle so
what if we just take something to find
yeah we got a full suite of equipping
and everything what if we just take like
one of these i don't know let's take our
rogue here
just take a plain old rogue we'll give
him a weapon
uh let's see what do we give him up up
here let's equip this dagger
to the rogue
all right i'm just kind of doing some
quick quick hacks here uh
rename this here to rogue there we go so
we equipped the weapon
a dagger does one to three melee damage
and let's just make it fight with a
monster so let's make this same monster
all right
and we can just make the battle now the
test if we use randomization on the
damage
it's gonna be up in the air but the
majority of the time the monster should
win because well the rogue's level one
and level one has less hit points than
the monster and his damage is less so
the monsters should in theory win most
of the time that's gonna be hard to test
because it's not something that's gonna
be always true or always false but
basically what we can do is go
while
uh monster one dot get or hp dot
get current
you know we're just making a pseudo
battle system we don't have a true
battle system but let's just make them
attack each other and reduce each
other's hp basically uh we can we can at
least assert that that sort of thing can
work in a loop and then we can design a
battle system based on those sort of
things but you know no ai or anything uh
we could maybe put a little one here but
it'd get really complicated all right
soon okay assert that monsters hp is
greater than zero
and
rogue dot well what are we gonna do get
current hp i think do we have that
function
the dot hp
wherever i put it i don't remember the
function name but if we go look at this
player character
we should see what do we got we got get
current hp alright that's fine
get current
hp
is greater than zero
so basically well
both of them have more
than zero hp they're both still alive we
may attack each other and see who comes
out on top so let's just go
uh this kind of brings up the need for
like an event queue so we can make them
happen at the same time but we're just
gonna hack it we'll just go like monster
one dot hb dot reduce current
all right yeah we gotta do it like this
is it reduce
what if we name this function let's go
to here
yes reduce current this uh
autocorrect is is just not helping at
all
it's just flat out failing
to assist so
usually you get some autocorrect popping
up here
but if you don't you just have to
remember your function names kind of
defeats the purpose of the autocorrect
if it doesn't actually work and we want
to reduce the current by
the robes attack melee attack basically
melee attack
and then we want to do the same thing
for the rogue rogue
dot
oh we have i think we have to take
damage in this case yeah i'll just go
monster one dot
attack
so they both take damage
they both are going to just get hit by
each other's melee attacks and
basically until one or both of them have
zero
hp left
and there's no great way to assert this
other than we could do
i guess we could assert is true
oh that one of them
has zero hit points basically
so we'll just make this funky looking
thing we'll just sand them together
uh this one
not hand we're gonna order them together
so either the monster's current should
be zero or the rogue's current
should be zero so one of these has to be
true all right we can just assert that
in a simple battle here
and we could even run this battle
multiple times if we want
but in general this should pass so let's
hit run all tests so that it builds our
new test
look for a simple battle to pop up there
it is it does fail
uh let's see why does it fail
[Music]
it's failing on this equip apparently
what am i missing here
weapon slot
cast to item
calling cast to armor
why are we casting it to armor
all right well uh this is a null
reference i think okay we're doing it on
this melee attack get equipped weapon at
so maybe we need to walk through this a
little bit and see where it's going
wrong but i think we messed up one of
our attack functions potentially this
one
see that's range that should be fine
that's melee that should be fine get a
quick weapon to get equip weapon
yeah so let's go back to our little
simple battle let's just put a
breakpoint like right here
and maybe here and we can right click go
to debug and just walk through it see
what's happening see where we're getting
this failure all right so let's uh step
over that one that's fine creating the
item works fine uh creating the monster
works fine now let's do it let's dive
into this while loop so let's go right
here here we go we're doing the rogues
melee attack let's see what's going
wrong here
we go to get equipped weapon it jumps up
here
and
just checks that this exists
gets the data turns that const pointer
uh maybe we don't want these final
well this shouldn't affect it but
get weapon at okay
gets the weapon
goes through this random
let's make sure these are actually the
values we expect one and three yep looks
good
looks good and then we're adding our
strength
and here's where we're having an issue
it's because all right we're checking an
armor slot that has nothing so this is
actually a problem somewhere else we
should have checked this earlier in a
test because what if
you the one you're passing in
this in item what if this is null we we
don't have that check going on here so
it's a it's trying to dereference some
null stuff and that's that doesn't work
obviously so basically what we want to
do here
is have a null check if n
if not in basically
uh we just want to return
and we probably want to do that in all
of these and we should have a test that
checks this somewhere else
right but let's just go ahead and hotfix
it like so then visual studio is having
a mind of its own and doing something
whatever
your thing
we just don't want to do the cast if
this n is
not is null so this is just a null check
let's run that again let's see if it now
is okay
yeah and it now passes
let's run it in the debug so we can step
into it if we want
so we know no this one's fine
oh let's uh get out of that
over that
yeah we'll skip over those current
checks
all right so this melee attack was
actually fine it was
the part where we were
totaling up
let's see let's get to it here random's
fine
it was this get total strength because
it was it checks every armor slot right
goes through every single armor slot
goes through every single weapon slot
if some of those are null
it was failing the cast
but not just a normal fail it was
failing because
it was going into this function here
and then trying to take a null pointer
and dereference it or get the data out
of a no pointer and yeah that whole
dynamic cast was epic failing so
in good catch there another reason right
test now in theory
so we know this works fine now we can
just continue and let it do its thing uh
we do want to stop here though let's
let's continue to the end let's see who
lost so get current this uh the monster
has seven hp left
the rogue would go look at his hp we
should be able to find it here somewhere
under player class i think
hp his current is zero
so he just got slapped around uh monster
only went down a seven rogue only went
down to zero so rogue stood no chance
even though he did have
looked like he had 12 hit points is that
right let's check the rope
we have him starting out with
yeah even though he had more hit points
he just did on an average so much less
damage
that he had no chance
so a little little imbalance maybe but
it gets the job done and
you can see the point here
we can now
basically have the battle we have
the core of a battle system worked out
although this is way too simple to
really use in a game i mean sure we
could we could just you know have him go
back and forth but in reality you want
to be able to use your actions and
anytime it's your turn you want to be
able to pick your abilities and stuff so
that's a whole other thing we have to
design but
we do at least have a base monster
system in here of monsters we could
create at will to battle
so
we'll have to manage that going forward
and i have to consider what they drop
but
this is probably just going to be
more of a base class
in the end
i don't know there's there's a lot of
design decisions to make here on this
whole monster thing like we could in
theory we could even just say hey just
make the monster basically another
player character we could turn this into
just like a living being delegate or
something you know
and we could do that with control r and
go living being delegate
and we could make this all the base
stuff for every living thing however we
don't necessarily want every living
thing to have levels experience so
that's why i'm not going to do that but
it kind of does make sense that they
should be able to get buffs and things
like that
so more design decisions that we're
probably going to ignore and we're just
going to leave monsters a whole separate
thing because there's going to be the
you know the four player character
classes and then things you can battle
against
and uh yeah we still got five more
episodes after this to go let me know
what you want to see next and maybe
we'll actually do in the next few
episodes because we have to start
finalizing some things here alright
thanks for watching peace out
[Music]
you